Ryan Serhant is the star of Million
Dollar Listing New York he sold over 6
billion dollars with real estate and
he's about to give us an inside look
into the 2023 housing market in a way
that you've never seen before you can
buy an apartment here for 2 million and
you'll sell it for five he's also
currently selling the most expensive
listing in the world right now selling
for 250 million dollars a penthouse in
New York and homes like those are sold
to billionaires as in with a B so we're
getting the behind the curtain look at
what billionaires are actually like
behind the scenes when there's no
cameras there's no nothing just Ryan
Serhant and them and the stories I gotta
say are insane so with that said enjoy
subscribe if you're not already and now
let's begin but first we want to thank
our sponsor Creative Juice as a Creator
you're running a business and as a
business you gotta have a business
banking account that's separate from all
of your personal stuff well fortunately
Graham Creative Juice is the perfect
place to get started choose funds
creative Futures so that you can stay in
control of your content and supercharge
your growth not only does juice provide
creators with funding it's a One-Stop
shop for all of your creator banking
needs think debit cards with rewards
invoicing team collaboration tools
paying your contractors real-time
analytics and more let juice automate
your business so that you can stay
focused on what matters the most which
is your content and I love that they
also offer funding like their juice
funds refresh and Reserve program that
allows you to get the funding you need
to make the content you want just choose
refresh for your short-term needs or
reserve for up to two million dollars in
funding to grow your business as an
investor in Juice myself I recognize
just how helpful funding could be juice
funds offers 100 Creator control
flexible dealings starting as short as
three months trust-based relationships
easy payouts and dedicated support from
industry experts you could use these
funds to purchase Studio space hire
freelance help or do anything else that
you believe will help expand the
business so sign up for a free Creative
Juice business banking account today by
using the link Down Below in the
description or by going to getjuice.com
getfunding so get started now and take
control of your creator business once
again guys it's completely free the link
Down Below in the description thank you
so much and on to the podcast well
thanks so much for making it on the iced
coffee hour Ryan sir hint I missed out
this morning you guys were touring a 250
million dollar Penthouse the most
expensive listing in the United States
is it in the world most expensive
listing in the world
I think so I think it's the most
expensive active active listing in the
United States there's definitely other
properties out there where people are
like you know uh this one is a hundred
you know a billion dollars there's off
markets in Malibu and Palm Beach that
are quietly marketed for half a billion
dollars you know but they're they're not
actively out there and this is your
personal listing or is it just we saw my
house I don't live there oh right right
unfortunately you know I'm just putting
one down my own crib right uh yeah one
day
um uh yes it's our it's our listing yeah
so we have it listed you missed out Jack
I was telling you didn't even get to see
it you didn't show up were you sleeping
no well I just wanted to make sure I was
ripe and tuned up for this podcast that
was my goal I was like okay I'll get
good sleep you'll stay in the same spot
no okay so you're not staying in Harlem
where he got a nice ritzy ritzy pad you
got a nice spot I think it's it's two
bedrooms wow that's nice for New York
that's pretty good yeah I'm staying with
my buddy Sean the guy that goes up asks
people questions on the street he's a
Kips Bay nice yeah so I'm there yes
I was trying to get Jack to go and he's
like oh no it's a good kind of it's like
Jack how often do you have the
opportunity to do this yeah no dude I'm
enjoying Kips Bay
31st right I'm just loving it he
compared it to a 45 million dollar home
in L.A he's like well if I saw that it's
good it's a really hard corner to get
myself out of that I've somehow put
myself in but like I've seen a 40
million dollar place in La and that just
like it blew my mind and I'm wondering
like okay what's the difference between
40 and 250 million so the average lay
man for me I see something I'm like I
don't even know what material that
countertop
you know what I mean yeah so I don't
know I would have loved to see the view
that's the one thing but I watched an
entire like Long YouTube video your
YouTube video on it yeah so I kind of
got like the you get it the feeling for
it Jake's the type of person like I
don't need to see the Great Barrier Reef
I saw a YouTube video on it yeah that's
the same thing I don't travel I've seen
Paris on TV you know what okay yeah
maybe I could I saw an Instagram picture
of it but exactly it looked lovely for
us from the video that I watched it was
yes and thanks for this we're like pinch
hitting for ice coffee hour in our
podcast studio in our Sirhan
headquarters and so on right now our
pleasure to Welcome to our set crazy
team by the way like it's very rare that
we do podcasts with people and they're
like one two three four five six other
people in the room yeah they're
stressing me out with how many of them
it's cool I like it yeah you create a
live audience honestly Graham's got you
yeah and you it's a two yeah yeah that's
it yeah it's nice you are busy by the
way could you walk us through your
schedule because even getting you for
like an hour I was talking to your team
or like we should do tick tocks and this
and that and then you're like yeah we
know we've tried we just can't we we
keep telling them this and I'm like I'll
tell them too I'll back them up on this
you are so busy like every hour of your
day is so finely scheduled where like I
have a heart out 10 15. I have to leave
I'll be there exactly at this time how
do you like what's your day like it
depends on the day I mean so there's
there's uh you know is a holding company
okay and underneath that are three
separate businesses so there's certain
real estate there is uh Sirhan Studios
right and then there's what we call
satellite staring at which is education
so and I run all three now there's great
lieutenants and people for all of them
I'm not doing everything right across
the board there's a lot of different
people but I'm incredibly involved in
all three businesses all day long so it
depends on the day real estate takes up
a significant amount of my time
underneath that there is there's real
estate resale right there's real estate
new Dev new development takes up a lot
of my time there's buy side sell side
stuff there's adx which is the tech
stuff there's there's just a lot there's
a lot of meetings there's a lot of
things that I got to do to keep the
business moving forward there's
recruitment there's growth there's
pitching where we're going to double in
size this year we're going to expand
into a lot of new markets so that's a
lot on the education side there's
non-stop content creation zooms lives
coaching the mentorship and on the
studio side then it's like where I have
time time then it's me creating personal
content which is tough which is why a
lot of our content is very like Run and
Gun jump in the car you know kind of
Vlog Day in the Life type of stuff or
real estate tours because that's then
what we do right um and then wherever
else I can then find time ends up being
wait I'm married I should I should see
her uh and then oh also I have a baby I
should see I should see her you know and
then I try to sleep and then you said
datter days was it was that your word
dad or days Saturdays no there's a book
called Dad or day that someone gave to
me when I when I was about to have Xena
and so it's um it's actually a really
sad book it's about a dad who just like
well I thought it was fun but it's like
this dad who hangs out with his daughter
all the time and then you know Saturday
is Saturday and they like have a plan
every week and she like has a notepad in
the kitchen where she writes down
everything I'm gonna do with Dad on
Saturday because he works all the time
yeah right now Saturday that's the day
and then in the it's like a kids book in
the book like Dad gets fired dad has to
get new job new job works on weekends
dad travels all the time no more dad on
dad or day and she like cries by the
window like cartoon everything the mom's
like Daddy still loves you and I like
read this book and I'm like what on
it's like insane and at the end like
they change the day it's like Saturday
can be any time right even in your
imagination because Dad can't afford to
spend time with you it's like it's it's
traumatized so I try to wait did you
read this to your child I do read it to
show you seriously she's like haha daddy
cry like yeah but
um yeah so Saturdays are Saturdays if
it's a normal week but like this past
weekend we were shooting one of our new
courses so I shoot all day Saturday I'll
do all day Sunday when we do the courses
because they can't do them during the
week this coming Saturday I gotta shoot
a new course Sunday's in a work day so
it's there's a lot of times where it's a
couple months on end where there's no
days off but then where I when I have
the time Saturday will be Saturday do
you have strict clock and clock out
times or is it kind of just like wake up
let's go and then go to bed
um no I'm pretty regimented it you know
it depends so on Sunday nights I'll I'll
talk to so my main assistant um is scale
and so we'll discuss calendar for the
next seven days and then I'll discuss it
with my wife Amelia just to determine
like hey
um part of our deal right is that I come
home to see Xena twice a week before she
goes to bed so I see her before she goes
to bed at least twice a week if that's
gonna be really hard then I'm also
taking her to school twice a week in the
morning so I drop her off at then 9am
um which is then you know which is
downtown
um so I try to see her a little bit more
other than that I would end up getting
home at like 9 10 P.M every single night
because if a client event or something
or I've got to stay in the office and I
would just like I would literally see
her on Saturdays only how earlier you
wake up 4 30. it's been wow it's been
the same forever what time do you go to
bed to wake up at 4 30. it depends
honestly it depends like the latest I'll
go to bed is 11 so like last night was
11. if I can if I could go to bed at
like 6 p.m I was so really right
um most times it's somewhere like
10 10 30 Monday through Friday okay
Saturday I won't wake up at 4 30. it
depends on again it depends on the day
and depends on the work and what I'm
doing
um so if it's a dad or day I'll like
work out at like 8 A.M but I still won't
sleep much later than like six you know
I just won't get I just won't move yeah
I'll just do what everyone else does or
I'll like lay there and be like no I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna look at three
more tick tocks sure right and then like
an hour later you're still tick-tocking
do you moisturize I do much no I asked
about his skin it just it looks
incredible your skin looks better than
mine I know 24. that is tell it tell
them about that what's your secret man I
thought dude I thought it was like it
had to be like botox because it looks
too purify you get like 12 hours of
sleep every night no no I backed under
my eyes now it's puffy those are in the
comments
um uh and it gets to me emotionally the
uh no dude I I bad skin when I was
growing up okay at bad skin when I was
growing up and I wanted to be an actor
so it like really affected me right I
was super sensitive about it like it
affected dating like this that the other
it was super oily had had bad acting and
then as that started to transition it's
not like my skin cleared up it
transitioned into like full-blown
rosacea like a 55 year old guy in
Colorado where like I always looked like
I was sunburned like I was bright red
and if I had caffeine or it was too warm
or like any kind of triggers like if you
look at it there's these triggers and I
would just be bright and I would just
walk in the rooms and people were like
oh man what are you what are you outside
all day man you got a lot of sun I'm
like no I have a disease and it's uh uh
you know it's not that big of a deal
when you're much much older but when
you're like 23 in New York City trying
to like get on a soap opera do theater
you know it's like that's what you're
known for if you're the guy that walks
in with premature gray hair and a bright
red face people are like oh you're the
gray-haired crayon like it's just you
know it gets to you
um and so uh I did low dose Accutane
um four times uh I did that four times
took a long time to clear up skin and
then from there I read a book by a guy
named Dr Nays called beating rosacea
that like saved my life and in it uh
actually in it he's the one who talked
about uh low-dose Accutane so I took
that and then there's a new laser
treatment it's not new anymore but at
the time it was new it's called v-beam
and so it would shrink it would shrink
the blood vessels in your face and
therefore the pores and limit your
sebaceous glands and so I did a v-beam
laser treatment and like my skin fell
off I looked like Freddy Krueger it was
insane
um and that it happens like the first
time you do it and I've done it like
every other December since then my skin
doesn't fall off anymore like you
wouldn't even notice I could do it today
you wouldn't notice
um but I've been good ever since
um but I also I wear SPF every day I
wear um an SPF every single day
um I wash my face twice a day with like
this mud soap and at night in this deep
cleanser in the morning and I don't know
a video in your skincare you really
should yeah he's got oh my gosh come on
I know why we don't do this stuff
I'm like okay it's it's not a full video
but that's a short it's viral that
that's a 45 to you know 60 seconds yeah
yes yes yes so SPF but I also listen at
the same time I I eat relatively pretty
clean
um I work out a lot so I sweat a lot
right so I sweat a lot so I clean my my
face a lot
um and then I also I don't really drink
I don't like to taste of alcohol like
I'll have a glass of wine once a week
and I don't smoke you know or anything
like that I think that also possibly
helps hey what about as far as going
gray when did you start noticing that 16
16 yeah what what was that experience
like did that run in the family did you
have someone like my dad said he started
graying when he was early and he's like
he'll be white by 30 and I was like
gross
um and it it you know it affected me
just like everything right like you're a
teenager and like anything that's if you
you know if you're not like on the
sports team everything about you is just
not right and so and I also like theater
so I was like bright red acne slightly
overweight and I like theater and oh
also I was growing so I was like sweet
awesome
um uh so when I moved to New York after
college no when I was in college I would
like Diet by myself with like the gloves
and the stuff and the Just For Men thing
um and then when I moved to New York all
but then I would go to like a hair salon
and diet but you know if you dye your
hair it feels weird you know it starts
to feel it's just like it's such a pain
in the ass because you have short hair
yeah like a woman dyes her hair she can
at least you know she grows it for a
little bit longer she's not she doesn't
have to do it every 10 days you were
doing it every 10 days my hair grows so
fast and so yeah every 10 days to two
weeks I'd have to go dye my hair so I
could go to these auditions in New York
City where people weren't like do you
have great tips like what's happening
like it just would look weird if you
look at like early soap opera days for
me on As the World Turns which is like
the first thing I did in New York I am
super pale
because I had Zapped all the redness out
right it was super pale and they were
dyeing my hair on set and they would dye
it so dark brown it would look black I
looked like I looked sick I looked like
Dracula like I was super pale with
really really dark hair and I would just
look like I like it I looked weak it was
just weird wow but now you're like yeah
but it's like a great marketing thing
for you now then I gotta do real estate
because then I ran out of money then I
was like what am I gonna do do I go home
do I you know stuff I think we talked
about on our last podcast a little bit
of that stuff and so then I just stopped
dying it because it was also either
expensive or I'd have to do it on my own
it was just messy just like screw it and
um when I first got into the business my
hair was still dyed because I just
looked weird like I was super young face
super old man hair and it looked weird
but then people would ask me like oh
you're young like should we really go
look at apartments with you
and then I don't remember I think I just
like forgot to I got lazy about dyeing
it and then I realized retroactively
people have stopped asking me how long
I've been in this business people have
stopped asking me like how young I am I
think they they like would look at me
and then look at my hair and then say
and you just must take care of himself
this 40 year old guy and I'd be like yep
that's me I've been doing this for a
long long time and then it just sort of
became my calling card like people would
start recognizing me from the back of my
head yeah because they'd be like what an
interesting assortment of salt and
pepper you know yeah I think when
Million Dollar Listing New York first
came out the first thing I noticed was
the hair and that just stuck out to me
it's just it's Unique it's not good or
bad it's just it's stable it is it was
just the silver thing and so then I've
just obviously I've obviously I've been
dyed it and it's just gotten farther
further and further gray ever since
next time next time we do this when we
hit the trifecta the hat trick for for
iced coffee hour I'll walk in Anderson
Cooper white and you'd be like oh you
finally made it like yep do you find
that stress or like a busy schedule
makes it gray faster or do you think
it's just all genetic at this point I
think the kickoff was definitely genetic
so I think there was a lot of genetics
to do uh to do with that but I also
think I live a pretty fast very high
stress life like I'm stressed all day
long are you motivated by stress it
drives you I don't know I think I'm I'm
motivated by pressure like I'll complain
about it but I I do live off of it I'm
motivated by by
um by like you know by timelines right
by deadlines like I'm motivated by my
schedule like my schedule doesn't have
to be crazy I kind of create the chaos
more than anything but
um I think the stress and the things and
all the stuff definitely does add to to
everything like you know workouts are
way harder for me than they ever used to
be the hair is definitely grayer the
bags under the eye you know it's slowly
and I become a product of my environment
you know I'm just like a product of New
York City it's the grime and you're
you're a fan of that intense lifestyle
constantly feeling like you're under
pressure and uh like you gotta catch up
or something you're a fan of that I
guess so I mean I I'm used to it now so
now it's like my normal you know it's
like when people we had Billy McFarland
on on our podcast talking about jail and
he was like he totally understands why
when people leave jail they go right
back because they get so used to the
structure they get used to the four
walls they hate it they complain about
it I shouldn't be in here the minute
they get out just like where my walls go
like I I nope got to do something to get
back in jail I want someone to tell me
what to do and I want someone to give me
my food at the right time they like the
habit and so I think there is some sort
of like masochism to the the addiction
that I have now to the insanity of the
schedule into the habit of the routine
mean but I do take breaks like dude
there is Dad or day I do go on vacations
now I never used to go on vacation my
wife's Greek they spend all summer in
Greece so now I have this baby baby so
I'll go to Greece for a week here a week
there and there's no 4 30 a.m's there
like I'm not I'm not a psycho it's often
people commit Petty crimes to go back to
jail
yeah because that's just their new life
yeah I know there's kind of a weird
parallel to draw but one thing I've
noticed was like if you know who liver
King is yes yeah so he lives a very
intense life yeah right like he's
working out like three times every day
just constantly putting himself under a
lot of stress and pressure yep and I
feel like it would be more challenging
for him to relax and more uncomfortable
to relax than to constantly be put in
this conventional discomfort of working
out yeah exactly yeah he's gonna feel
empty he's gonna feel lost you need the
energy that way if you're that type of
person I don't know sometimes I'm like
man I wish I could just be someone who
goes with the flow like hey there's a
dinner I gotta go to the dinner I like
uh you know we do that or friends saying
hey you want to come hang out and I'd be
like yep yep yep you basically have
gotten used to this very intense
lifestyle and you're a fan of it now but
sometimes you do wish that you could
have a more relaxed schedule yeah I just
don't think I'm I'm type of person who
can just wing it like I know people who
you know are in the real estate business
who like don't even like they don't have
a calendar like I know like there's an
agent I know who does like a billion
dollars a year and she like she ever
counted on her phone she's like nope how
do you know where to go she's like oh I
get a printout for my assistant like how
do you know who to call and what to do
and she's like oh I guess I kind of
remember like do you ever forget
anything she's like oh my God I forget
things all the time but she does a
billion dollars a year so does it
actually matter she has her way of
operating I have my ridiculous way of
operating there's other everyone's got
their own way you just have to do the
way that ends up working for you yeah
how often are you showing properties now
I showed properties today so I was with
you this morning yeah so I guess I
showed that to you okay and then I went
with a client I had to show properties
um uh which is more and more and more a
rare occurrence you know I I I'll handle
VIPs now like VIPs special property
special things I need to show also still
you know showing don't know the other
day where one of our agents needed me to
show and I I showed like I'll do that if
I have the time and if I can schedule it
and I can I can make it happen but my
time is probably not best used showing
anymore now that we're you know building
and growing the business
is there a threshold like in terms of
the dollar amount that if a client says
I want you to show me properties uh 15
million dollars like is that a threshold
where you would say okay I'm gonna drop
my schedule or make out a day for this
I'm just curious at what level you would
say that you would spend your time doing
showings or walking on one client
particular depends if it's a if it's a
personal referral client to me you know
someone says you know hey Ryan I need
you to take out this person like I was
just with uh a personal referral who's a
very very important client and it was to
help them find a rental for their
daughters right and like I typically
wouldn't do that if I don't know the
person but for them like I'm there right
I'm showing them around that's that's my
job and I don't ever really want to lose
that
um uh you know it depends it depends
also on future business I care very much
about future so if it's a one-time
person they come through and they have a
10 million dollar budget you know if I
if I can balance that time then I can
take it but oftentimes it's never a
quick thing it takes forever then they
change their mind then they want to rent
something then so I always work with
with agents here it's a big part of our
lead flow like I gave out
700 leads last year alone just agents
here not even part of our like Sirhan
connect referral Network there's a lot
of lead flow to agents that work
um at sirhant everywhere and so they'll
take those people
but typically like if it's like 20
million and above like I'll be there
personally and it'll end up making sense
for for time I just wanted to know what
the difference is like because I'm sure
it's not the same structure that you
follow if you're selling a 250 million
dollar house to selling like a you know
500 000 town home somewhere else like
what differences for the for the average
person can you expect if you're like I'm
sure you're probably not throwing open
houses right no it's 250 million dollar
players could you know we'll do like
we're doing a very very high fashion
event at the big pen house right coming
up um we've done a couple like hedge
fund dinners and things so we'll do we
won't do open houses on Sundays from two
to three p.m right imagine that yeah
we would never be allowed to and it
would just be bad um but we'll do the
alternate version which are like
targeted marketing events where you get
the right types of people in the space
and it's something we're really really
good at doing and it's it's a part of
why we get hired is we can bring the
right eyeballs both virtually digitally
and in person to a space to try to get
the absolute best price and to sell it
because for a place like that right
something that's asking 250 million
dollars
um uh someone's gonna buy it
and that person's not going to even know
that they wanted to buy it they're going
to make the decision
um once they find out about the property
and they're going to say Let's go see
that that thing looks crazy they know
they can afford it but they're not like
house hunting you know it's not like
they decided honey we need a new seven
bedroom in New York budget somewhere
between 20 million and 500 million like
that's not how people think these
properties are always sold you know um
and they're sold typically spur of the
moment like I sold a house in Palm Beach
last year
um pretty famously for just under 140
million dollars and I met that guy on a
Tuesday
to find things in New York City we've
decided to look in Florida randomly on
Wednesday we flew to Florida on Thursday
we were in contract on that place by
Friday and the budget he gave me was
plus minus 20.
and so I showed him a place that was
asking 140 and he walked around and then
I showed him other things that you know
I thought he was going to potentially
buy he hated them all bought that big
one how does it work if he wants to buy
here and just like on a whims like no
I'm actually going to move to Florida
because how does that happen when you're
worth yeah I know yes for us like
stressful right like what am I going to
do go tell my wife hey Babe by the way
we're moving across the country like you
know um but for somebody like that you
know what changed he's a
um it was a conversation that I had with
him about like the necessity of being in
New York at the time right like you're
looking in New York City uh it's an
interesting market right now you you
need to be here no and he said he didn't
need to be there and so he kind of
sparked that initial convo he's like
listen we're everywhere we're kind of
all over the place but you know we're
coming back to New York I think we
should probably get a place oh you
should probably get a place could you
work from anywhere yeah I could work
from anywhere and we had so many clients
that I was selling to in Florida we were
doing deal after deal in Florida it was
like you ever thought about Florida he's
like I don't know like Miami I'm like no
no you don't have to go to Miami like
what about Palm Beach there's a lot of
Finance types who are in Palm Beach it's
like oh maybe you know potentially like
you know you should talk to your
accountant like about the potential tax
savings it's the beginning of the year
if you declare residency there I don't
know how much money you make but New
York City tax I mean You're Gonna Save
10 right more right how much safe tax
here in Manhattan so is that on top New
York New York State and New York City
tax I think you end up saving somewhere
between 13 and 15 wow so it's it's a lot
right and so
um and everything all included right and
because then you've got New York City
property tax and everything combined and
so it ended up being this massive tax
savings and so yeah so that those things
can happen really really quickly it's
the two million dollar buyers that'll
look for three years no but now I'm
curious when you decide to fly to Palm
Beach do you guys get in a private plane
do you book like a class or like
sometimes I can I can catch a ride most
times I catch a ride
to be completely honest
like
you know I love all my clients equally
but if I'm going to fly with you and
it's private like there's no movies
we're not getting like yes there's
there's a there's a flight attendant
right you're there but like they're
there and now I have to sit here
for hours and we are just going to talk
and sometimes that's good yeah sometimes
it's like
I gotta think about what to talk to you
about like how am I going to talk about
real estate the entire and then you're
gonna ask me all these questions what if
I don't know the question like it's a
lot so on that one I met him there
interesting so you feel pressured to
like be friendly with them and to like
continue the conversation stuff like
that for me it would be the intimidation
of just like you don't want to screw
this up at least that's how say
something dumb or like a joke that
doesn't land I don't really get nervous
about saying anything dumb I get nervous
about like
can I relax in front of this guy like if
I slouch funny or if I'm like I you know
because we do a lot back and forth
between California and different places
and like if I'm Gonna Fly private with
someone I just met let's say right
sometimes
um for five hours like American Airlines
sounds real nice you know like I'll just
sit up this is stressful let's do my
yeah me there because you're gonna spend
so much time with that person on the way
but that's also the type of like it's
it's probably one of my weaknesses right
there's plenty of people who can take
that situation turn it into 100 other
situations and they would like Envy it
and eat it up and I I can do that right
with with certain people
um uh but a lot of times you know I find
too that you end up spending time on the
plans and they're reading the whole time
in your reading
quietly
in an airplane kind of feels like an
Uber where you can never really tell
like sometimes you just want silence and
or sometimes they're doing what and
you're like are they just angry today is
it a bad day or they just want to give
you space yeah or they're doing work you
know
um which is totally which is totally
fine
everyone I work with for the most part
ends up being like a real pleasure to
work with and they're great it's more
just my personal insecurities and and
issues of why like sometimes I'll just
I'll just meet you there and remember
too when they fly private they leave on
their terms it's not my terms so a lot
of times guys will say hey we're gonna
fly down tomorrow eight o'clock you want
to fly with us say yes and then they
don't show up because they had a meeting
it's not they don't care about my
schedule right they come like an hour
late something else or they're like yeah
we're gonna leave tomorrow now I flew
with them let's say now we're super late
now I gotta wait for him to fly back and
he decides oh we're not gonna fly back
on Friday I think we go back Sunday cool
I'm like
does that I have a life does that happen
oh yeah yeah that's why they fly private
so they don't have to operate within any
one other timeline other than their own
you know and so like you then get stuck
that way and it's like okay well I gotta
go now book a commercial airline it's
fine have you ever thought about flying
private or no you know what we we've
flown private once to Canada and it was
the worst why is everyone laughing is
there why is there I feel like there's
this because they were stuck with me
because uh no one told us that to fly
internationally especially into Canada
to to get to leave there's one phone
number you call and you gotta wait for
like one guy to get on the phone to give
you clearance and to give you the code
and then you can take off and we it to
we like waited an hour
hour and a half and then you land you
gotta call the same guy before you can
get off the plane like we literally have
content where we were just like getting
real claustrophobic on this little plane
sitting there and they're like sorry it
never takes this long I'm like has it
ever taken this long before and they
were like well yes actually like we must
get off this play it was awful we all we
just took we just flew commercial on the
way back we're like thanks so much yeah
because it's like crucial Airlines
they're big they're fast you know they
they're easy you can have snacks you do
your own thing it's fine you know if you
have TSA or clear like you're not you
know it's not that much of a pain in the
end it's like it's it's fine and you
save so much money I'm like you like I
don't wanna it's I I just like I don't
want to spend the money like you look at
this building like we have this whole
building in the middle of Soho right you
have the whole building yeah is there
anything in here that you that you
sublease no it's all us it's not the
whole building how many square feet is
that fifteen thousand fifteen thousand
square feet can you see where the rent
is uh I don't know what my rent is right
now I think the rent is 75
000 a month how much would this building
be worth if you were to purchase it
oh A Lot 25 a lot yeah I do not pay a
rent that's commensurate with with what
it would actually be worth okay right
it'd be worth a lot um it would sell for
a lot like I think Gucci across the
street just sold for like 100 million
dollars as a store one floor this is
four floors
that's the one thing I noticed in New
York as far as the cap rates are
concerned or any sort of return that you
get on most Apartments buildings three
three and a half percent yeah if you're
lucky all the times you're just looking
to carry costs because New York City is
because New York City is built on
appreciation it's like we combined
apartment here for two million and
you'll sell it for five if you can hold
not all the time but like it's in a
commercial to retail do you think
there's ever a chance that maybe it
doesn't see the appreciation long term
because people are working from
computers they're going to Florida now
but I I would say like
work from home has not changed New York
City's real estate business irreparably
like it it slowed it down for a hot
minute but now you have different types
of people right like there's always just
a big Changing of the Guard it's like
when China putting Capital controls and
all of a sudden all the Chinese money
dried up that was feeding New York City
real estate then it switched it was
different countries that all of a sudden
came through and when currency moves
right we watch currency exchanges a lot
when there's currency moves money will
come in or that money will leave right
then you start reaching out to foreign
clients and just say hey just so you
know we're par now or up it would be a
good time for you to sell you'll make 20
more at the same price than you would of
a year ago start to have those types of
conversations I'm curious because the
typical person that would buy a 250
million dollar Penthouse would they're
probably a billionaire yeah I would say
at the point yeah ten times over many
times over yes so you're probably in
contact with a lot of different
billionaires right yes is there any
trends that you've noticed amongst like
the ultra wealthy the people that like
you know I could potentially never meet
my entire life the average person could
never meet some trends that you've
noticed maybe about their personality
their characteristics they're super
normal for the most part I've never met
like some of them are quirky but they're
they're just like us like they just
happen to be way wealthier do you think
that there's a trend like some character
trait or personality trait they're on
guard
they're always on guard at being taken
advantage of for the most part like
everything like did they charge me too
much here did they charge me too much
there like you can see it kind of in the
corner of their eye Graham's gonna be a
billionaire now they're just like I'm on
the right track there you go they're on
guard and they also uh they do not waste
time
like they don't waste time there's no
like literally no wasting of the time
because their time is so much better
spent elsewhere and they will make
massive decisions incredibly quickly
because they they trust their ability to
make decisions fast it's probably the
biggest thing that I've taken away from
working with billionaires versus working
with everyone else and something that I
think a lot of us can really you know
replicate and learn from it's like
I see so much analysis paralysis in
decisions that have absolutely no need
for it like I'll go to dinner with a
billionaire client they order like the
waiter comes over to get water orders
are made there's no just like it is not
that they're in a rush for dinner it's
there is no benefit to the time to me to
look to think what could I want oh dude
what about the chicken you want the
chicken do you think the state let me
look I'm gonna Google review there's no
[__] time for that like life is short
and they they get it more than anybody
else
um five clients who are far far far far
less wealthy and the amount of time they
take to think about decisions and this
that and the other just like
I I you know I don't say it but inside
I'm like if you're a billionaire this
people are so much faster you know this
would be moving so much like I'm dude
like sitting in here
I missed like eight phone calls I've
noticed that that's okay oh my gosh yeah
it's a lot but like you know right now
yeah this one guy so this guy is a
billionaire he's texting me he's like
please call me back let's make offers on
both let's try to come in a little bit
lower let me know what numbers you want
to start at this is like a 40 million
dollar apartment he's trying to go back
and forth in between the two so I gotta
call him back
um and he's just gonna do over text I'm
gonna call him back and he's not gonna
pick up right and then he's gonna text
me what he wants me to do they also text
a lot more than anyone else do they sell
voice memos no because they don't want
their voices recorded I'll do like I'll
negotiate something for 1.5 million and
and the client will need an in-person
meeting right they're going to bring
their private Banker they want like they
want their attorney on the phone you
negotiate with someone who's worth
multiple billions of dollars and it's
like a DM because they just don't care
and they don't have the time to to waste
and they'll text their ideas and their
thoughts so when it comes time to
actually signing something then there's
absolutely a team of very smart people
that are that are risk assessing like is
this the right thing to do but it's um
it's an interesting World a lot of that
what I've seen with at least actors is
that they are very rarely involved
they'll look through it they'll okay I
like it all right you're gonna talk to
this person now yeah and for the rest of
the deal you don't even communicate with
that I know it's so someone else yeah
who's making all the decisions on their
behalf you'll call them sometimes say
hey this is what we're doing are you
okay oh yeah I know whatever they say
this is oh you know I'll listen to them
yeah and that's it celebrities do that
yeah right I deal with that all the time
celebrities models athletes it's so
annoying because especially in athletes
they're handlers like the athletes
handlers aren't you know there's
business managers right there's there's
the bankers Etc but it's like yeah
you're gonna talk to Richie I've known
Richie since I was two and Richie is a
pain in these initiator he's a
negotiator but he also he's got his own
interests uh like he does his own he's
got his own people that's why a lot of
times you see celebrities running around
with with Brokers or people you're like
who how did you ever even get involved
it's because the Richie of that you know
of that celebrity and friend
relationship is getting paid by Bobby
you're gonna work with my buddy Bobby
you're like Bobby you're giving me 50 of
whatever Leo buys and so like whereas
Leo where he could just come to it
happens all the time yeah and it's this
and then the celebrity doesn't even
question it because they have so much
trust and faith in their friends because
they've been with them forever that they
don't even think about the Kickbacks
that this friend is getting the whole
time and how he's living off of you
whereas like you know we'll I do deals
for free with celebrities they come to
me and I'm like I just want the
relationship anyone you know because you
know a lot of people I don't need to
make money on your sale I'll sell it
I'll sell it for free I'll rent you this
place for free I won't charge
commissions or anything and yet they end
up working with other people where the
commission is actually more because
Richie says Leo that's how it's got to
get done here sorry buddy sorry buddy
when he's actually being taken advantage
and it's like poor poor celebrities
[__] up but now at the billionaire
level how often do they generally
negotiate on a deal because I would
imagine a lot of these cases it's not
even worth their time it's like the more
time they spent even negotiating like
five million off yeah but they don't
want to get it bad yeah or how much of
it is purely just they want to get a
good deal it's a good deal if they don't
want to be taken advantage of they just
want a good deal
um and they are you know they take it
personally too because it could also be
written about yes like there's no
billionaire out there who's like secret
you know for them you know and so if
it's gonna be written about there's ego
right there's involvement like now all
their employees are gonna know what they
just spent you know if they don't bury
it right they're employees are going to
know they're wiser than it the Ex-Wives
are gonna the kids are gonna know the
kids in their kids school are going to
know oh your dad just bought that big
place my daddy said he overpaid your
daddy's an idiot like that [__] happens
of course Man kids are the worst like
you know it's going to be written about
in the papers all of a sudden the
company doesn't have a bad year it's
like ah well the CEO overpaid for that
property earlier this year the
shareholders must be pissed now they're
calling for his ouster right now they're
trying to take down his pay like it all
yeah it all feeds into together so do
they have time to negotiate and does
another million or two here or there
make any difference makes sense probably
not but money's money and most most
billionaires that that I work with
didn't start that way right they they
they they worked incredibly hard to get
the money or the valuations that they
have in some way shape or form
um and they're going to keep it that way
that's interesting how easy would it be
to keep that Anonymous why don't more
people just do Anonymous property sales
put it under trust you try people talk
yeah dude people talk like that deal I
did in Palm Beach it was buried it was
buried in llc's there's nothing public
about that everywhere it was a cash
purchase done incredibly quick no one
would know
problem is it's not the only thing we
saw right so we saw a bunch of other
houses and then reporters they're always
talking to different Brokers and
different people and then like you know
I I know I know that's how it got found
out one of the agents on one of the
houses that we went to that my guy did
not buy
was just jealous and spiteful and angry
and probably called up a reporters like
hey I know who bought that house yeah
yeah [__] him this is who it is because
they know it's going to be upsetting
it's going to make me look bad because I
was supposed to bury it and but I always
tell everyone we're gonna do everything
we possibly can I've sold properties for
billionaires yeah no one will ever know
they don't know about the deal they
don't know about the property I've never
posted about it I don't talk about it
like no one no one no one knows but then
there are the few that there's just
nothing you can do how do you prevent
that from happening in the future with
having another agent or or could be even
like a doorman let's just say see
someone walk in and they're like I think
that maybe that's the so I mean I did
this uh we sold a place in the Hamptons
once uh
between 19 I guess for 40 million
dollars to an incredibly well-known very
wealthy person and to really really
protect that that wouldn't happen he
never came no one came I did everything
over face time and he wouldn't even put
the camera to him he had the camera on
his desk facing this way he wouldn't
talk or anything and I just facetimed
him through and he could see the camera
to the side on his phone and I walked
him through and he bought that place for
for 40 just over FaceTime that way and
everything's buried it's owned in two
separate llc's wow how do you verify
though because it's a trail somewhere
like how do you know how does that
person even approach you the client
approached me yeah how does it how did
that connection
was made I met him
a long long time ago way before way
before he was that wealthy but then
let's why why the not even showing a
face on face because we don't want the
listing agent to know who it is we don't
want anyone else we don't want each
other the listing agent yeah like I'm
representing him so we don't want anyone
else the gardeners the attitude people I
was with the celebrity earlier today and
it's like you walk outside and people
just take photos take photos and now
they see him coming out with me right
and so people immediately know what it's
about and so there's there's no way
around it so I'll go in different doors
they'll go in different doors or we'll
do things virtually there's always
there's always ways but sometimes
um uh it's funny like we sold uh I did
the first resale at 220 Central Park
South uh for 33 million dollars to Igor
tulchinski awesome guy like a hardcore
such a cool guy uh very wealthy guy
um and I had the same conversation with
him and his people right said just so
you know if like because that was that
depths of covet nothing like that was
strange it was ten thousand dollars a
foot like if you buy this right and then
he also want to go to Palm Beach so he
bought a place for 40 million dollars in
Palm Beach
um so if you do these deals
I'm going to do everything possible to
keep this quiet and his identity was
pretty hidden because he had a huge huge
mask I've never seen a mask like this
fully masked all the masks he had all of
them yeah
um back when we had to wear masks all
the time and I was like someone's going
to find out and he's like
oh good do you think we could put this
in the Wall Street Journal yes we can
actually I know exactly how to do that
and he gave them a quote he gave them
um a photo a great photo hey these great
articles written about
um how he did it and it was just a
different just different mentality
different Spin and I think also in his
business too
I I think there's probably a correlation
between the more successful he is buying
trophy real estate
this is business the more successful his
business is so then people are like oh I
want to invest money with that guy I
think Isaiah like sure what's his
business certificate
Finance okay yeah I could see the
correlation yeah
I mean that makes sense
how much uh Ken Griffin's not that quiet
oh my gosh his purchases his art
purchases are everything he bought this
he bought the Constitution yeah and what
was the price it was like 50 million
dollars yeah 43 or 42. yeah his son told
him to buy it is he in New York he has a
place in New York he has all the places
in Florida Palm Beach and Miami wow and
Chicago and everywhere else so what do
you think the difference is in terms of
privacy between some people and others
like it seems like Igor was very much
spin it around as a positive this is a
good thing I think it's it's it's listen
everyone's different right like there
are real estate brokers in New York who
do amazing amazing transactions you
don't see them in press ever they have
no social media accounts no nothing and
then there's [__] guys like me who
are like the exact opposite sure you
know it's um I don't know people just
they I think people built their they
build their businesses differently I
don't know how to have my career without
being as out there as I am it's how I've
generated business since day one yeah
right through the power of content
through promotion the more people who
know what I sell the better I've never
had the opportunity to be quiet about it
you know whereas a lot of agents who are
very very quiet and are very successful
if they were to all of a sudden try to
generate business by being loud it would
hurt the book of the business that they
built over such a long period of time
based on the fact that they are a
complete unknown but very powerful yeah
in the industry how many homes do you
usually sell from social media how many
leads have brought in from let's say
tick tock or YouTube oh I mean
uh we probably get 10 to 15 leads a day
right how many of those convert into
transactions over time it's not all day
every day
um but it's probably I mean I don't know
might be 10 of that okay you know it's
still fantastic one a day and that's
from social media oh yes yeah 100 by
leads you just mean like a client that
wants to sell their home that wants
buyers yeah they want to sell or they
want to buy or they're interested in
something they want to you know let's be
in touch or they're reaching out
specifically about a listing because we
do a lot of promotion for the listings
the new developments everything in
general there's a great like when we
started the company
and I I had this idea of creating a a
content to Commerce funnel for all
things sales sales people and people who
need sales people
um uh and it was just weird right uh we
we listed a building in Brooklyn we did
the tour we did everything we we
optimized it a girl saw it and came
through saw the video never even thought
about buying over there bought an
apartment for 2.3 million dollars and
then gave a quote to like the New York
Post about why she bought there
and it was like some of the best press
we've had as a company and we have a lot
of press but I took that because now I
can use that with everyone to go through
like hey just so you know
proof is in the pudding like even if it
creates one more deal or two more deals
to to put property in front of eyeballs
that otherwise would not have known
about the property who could then
potentially purchase it
better yeah we sold 15 million dollar
townhouses because a 16 year old
daughter saw the video as we targeted
that type of market showed her parents
parents said oh I wasn't looking at that
location but I'll go take it and they
bought it
it's wild how is it different than
selling a 250 million dollar listing
what's are you taking a different
approach with like social media are you
taking maybe the stance that more views
the better on something like this and
get it out there are you trying to
curate the right type of views could you
explain how that's different
yeah I mean we
I mean listen if something's
two and a half million dollars right
we we could put it all over the world
and it's not gonna make a difference
right we want great exposure but it's
super targeted like we know that that's
probably going to be a local renter or
someone who owns a smaller apartment
looking to upgrade someone in probably
the immediate tri-state area or like an
investor base right that's about it for
something that's 250 million dollars I
need to go and find somebody that can
afford it that doesn't even know they
want it so it's it's a mixed campaign
of Target marketing and mass marketing
so Mass Market through content and it's
not just about views right it's the
sharing because I don't care about the
people who see it I care about how many
times it's been engaged with and how
many people share it because they're
sharing it to somebody who could share
it to someone else and share it to
someone else and at that point we don't
know how many times it gets shared
because people will see it right and
it'll most oftentimes be a kid and a kid
will see it who'll show it to another
kid who showed to another kid who show
it to his mom who works for a guy who
works for the buyer right and it's this
trickle up theory of kind of how content
to Commerce ends up working it's not
trickle down right it's trickling up the
ladder that way and so it's really
really interesting and then we we enact
like a real targeted campaign of
personal Outreach to these people right
if you can afford it you need to know
about it and we're getting it in front
of you or we're getting it in front of
your business managers or your private
Bankers or your lawyers how do you how
do you do that in such a way that
doesn't seem like pitchy I mean it is
pitchy but you keep it super simple
right you're like hey
Mr billionaire my name is Ryan sariant
we just listed the highest residential
home on Earth
I know you like trophy property if you'd
like to tour let me know here's some
information like you're not wasting time
you're not like oh my God you need like
super super super simple and people
respond you'd be surprised really yeah
they respond right or they'll send it to
someone who will then respond who will
reach out said Oh Mr so-and-so received
an email from Ryan about a property we
we'd like to ask is that on the accident
you know they have questions and so it's
so it works so it's Target plus Mass you
bring it together and that's how you
sell I feel like billionaires are people
of that status would be so privy to like
people pitching them and trying to add
extra details and stuff like that so
they'd be they would appreciate a nice
concise you know like not you got to be
simple exactly like I always remember
that phrase right kiss keep it simple
stupid all the time don't waste anyone's
time don't be overly pitchy don't
introduce yourself for two parents no
one gives a [__] right and they all have
funnels and filters to get rid of all
the stuff so like all the apps that
these guys are being pitched all the
time and all the nfts and all the Crypt
and all this stuff and all the new
business ideas it's funneled and someone
will look through through it you know
sometimes or just goes to junk but we
have ways of getting in front of people
you know where they actually will have
to see it and make a decision there's a
lot of different ways that we've
perfected over the years can you share
any of those or is that a trade secret
or if it's a trade secret but if I say
it here then other Brokers will use my
[__] you know okay so probably keep that
stuff to us okay how often is it if you
get reached out to by a billionaire is
it like the billionaire themself or is
it usually just like the you know their
assistant or something like that
sometimes like if it's email or phone
it's them directly because you get
people's phone numbers and you call them
and they pick up the phone right and you
have two seconds to make an impression
email they'll respond but if they're
like want to sell something or they want
to buy something it's hardly ever them
it's it's one of their handlers one of
their people who will reach out and
oftentimes you won't know who it is
until you start to figure it out how's
the New York Market changing right now
with higher interest rates it definitely
took a beating last year I think like
most markets did right the minute the
monthly cost doubled really really
quickly everyone kind of said wait can I
afford this
um uh the biggest difference is with
with doubled rates as fast as they've
gone I think you've talked about this
too you have sellers who are just locked
in so the inventory stays low so you've
kind of got this you know real estate
stagflation which is sellers can't
afford to sell because they can't buy
where they want to go they can't go get
a bigger place they can never afford it
and they have a low rate so why sell so
the general construction business has
gone through the roof home renovations
like you cannot get people because
people can't move they can't afford to
go buy something there's then nothing on
the market because sellers aren't
selling buyers don't know what to do
because inventory is so low and then
sellers end up just renovating so like
even my little brother outside boss he's
like dude I he's like I can't afford the
house I want to anymore you know what
the monthly payment would be so we're
doing an addition but the addition now
costs double what it did even a year ago
because everyone is doing additions it's
weird it's just huge disparity between
current payments and what people got
locked in yeah two years ago and you had
like the same unit same building same
everything one person is paying 10 000 a
month the other person's paying five
thousand dollars for the same unit
similar price yep it's too bad that
loans are unassumable
like if someone was able to sell that
three percent loan it would be worth a
lot of money correct there are markets
where you can do that you can do it in
commercial I've noticed that yes yes you
can do it in commercial
um which is why the commercial Market
hasn't changed right and it makes
properties even more valuable because
you can then you're purchasing someone's
right residential uh at least in New
York the only thing you can assume is
you can assume the amount of the loan
and therefore bypass what is in New York
City called the mortgage recording tax
of two percent of the loan amount but
you are going to have to get today's
rate and we were talking to someone on
the podcast the other week who was
saying that um
do on sale Clause is rarely ever
enforced if you continue just making the
payments have you ever experienced that
before like the bank just calling yeah
in terms of let's say you sell the
property but you keep the mortgage and
you just make the payments on the
mortgage no I've never I've never seen
that before
neither have I never mind we had someone
else on the podcast who says he does
this all the time really and has not had
an issue with the banks I think twice
yeah but he resolved the issues yeah it
was not an issue yeah interesting no
yeah in our markets and our price modes
have never seen that maybe in lower
prices it could be the lower price
points where it's different 500 Grand
yeah
it could be yeah um I want to be
respectful for your time I know it's
almost uh yeah I gotta go sell something
now yeah 3 30. good timing uh is there
anything else you want to mention
anything you want to throw up here pitch
well you just came and did our new
podcast yes the business of influence so
make sure to go check it out right go
check it out your Episode by the time
you put this up is probably gonna be up
and it's it's awesome I'll link to it
that means right after this you could
click that and then you could watch that
there you go perfect
keep watching in the link in the
description more Graham that's what we
should do watch me for another hour more
Grand yeah
um yeah I would love for everyone to go
check that out I mean cool I'm
everywhere but they should go check that
out we'd love to love cool thank you so
much
until next time